the acronym erp stands for enterprise
resource planning
an erp system is a core enterprise
software and solution stack
comprised of a central database
surrounded by multiple plug-in services
and software packages
each of which is tailored to solve
specific enterprise problems
and address specific challenges at the
core of all erp solutions is a master
database
this database houses all the records
that a company uses
within all of its erp solutions
these records can be financial like
invoices and purchase orders
they can be related to payments like
accounts payable and payroll and taxes
they can be related to inventory status
so that a company knows what its supply
lines are
and how many of all finished goods are
available in every warehouse
that core database also stores all of
the sales data
what customers have ordered what
products as well as details and
specifics on the internal processes
to get that product from the warehouse
to the customer
but simply storing the data by itself
isn't useful
the importance of an erp system is to
take all the data that a company
collects
and use it and integrate it so that that
company can find ways to
increase efficiency and save on costs
this is why there's always a data
analytics piece that wraps around the
entirety of that core
erp database this analytics engine is
busy
as it's constantly creating reports on
regular schedules and
updating the tables themselves but it
also has to have the ability to provide
data to users
on an ad hoc basis whenever a user has a
specific query
that they need more information from so
for all that data to flow correctly
into the database and for the core
functions of the erp system to work
correctly
let's talk about the most commonly
implemented modules that you'll find
within an erp system
so that first module that's going to be
your sales module
that is all of your sales data your
order data
your customer data so what customers
buying what things
where it's going shipping tracking all
of the po information on how it's
getting paid for in the payment status
you've got to track all of that sales
data but in order to make sales happen
you've got to have product in order to
have product that means that you've got
to have procurement
so for procurement you've got to go out
there you've got to track what materials
am i buying who am i buying them from
where are they coming from
am i getting the best deal am i doing
all of the things that i need to do to
acquire
what i need to make my product but
procurement goes so much further than
that it's not just what does it take to
make your product
it's also are you procuring what you
need in order for your employees to keep
up and running
are you buying things as complex as
servers to go into a data farm
and as simple as packages of ballpoint
pens so that people have something to
sign with
all of those pieces go into that
procurement area
and then in addition to the procurement
you've got to have your production
systems
right production is incredibly important
because you have to track that
production
from the very beginning with your raw
materials to the very end with your
finished product
and production is going to track
everything in between it's going to do
the planning the capacity management the
maintenance the materials management
being sure that the right things are
being staged at the right place at the
right time
particular as we've moved into this just
in time manufacturing process
everywhere in the world so that we get
as much efficiency
in our manufacturing process as we can
and so after we finish that procurement
we might have a distribution module
that module is going to be concerned
with how do we get our finished products
from point a to the customer's door or
just from point a
to the loading dock door so that
distribution model that's going to be
warehouse processes and staging goods
and movement of finished goods
logistics control inventory control
stock levels trigger levels all of those
things that are necessary
from a logistics perspective because
every business runs with that logistics
trail
and so your distribution modules have to
keep track of
all of that they've got to run all of it
for you or you're just going to run into
inefficiencies
and then related to manufacturing and
still very important
you've got your asset pieces right so
you've got your assets
and you have to track them these are
fixed assets capital assets
you have to know everything about them
not just the procedural information
what do you have who made it how does it
work what's its status
does it have any maintenance coming up
is it still under a service contract
those things are important don't get me
wrong but your finance department is
going to insist
that you also have all of that finance
related data what's the valuation of
your asset
what's its depreciation status what is
it
is its expected useful life should they
be planning on a capital expenditure in
order to replace it in a certain number
of years
tracking all of that is key to the asset
part because again
this fits in holistically and so
all of these services these are all the
back office ones
back office is important but also
important
is front office and this is the point
where we should cut back to me doing
this very nice scripted speech
so let's talk about these front office
customer facing or customer touching
solutions
things like customer relationship
management software right
that's your crm piece why does crm
matter well crm matters because that's
everything to do with your relationship
to that customer
it's customer information sales history
it's incoming leads on people who are
potentially interested in buying your
products
it's opportunity from first
identification to opportunity close
it's all of your sales tracking data and
your pipeline information that you
report out on
all of that goes into that crm system
that data is essential to knowing the
status
of your company and knowing what your
revenue is going to be
as you track all of those opportunities
from open to close
and then in addition to your crm suite
you've also got your hcm suite right
human capital management or
hr software there's lots of different
names for it but the same general idea
how are you going out and sourcing new
employees how are you retaining the ones
that you already have how are you being
sure that everybody is being judged
appropriately
that annual reviews are going well that
all of the back end processes
necessary to onboard and hire and
maintain and pay your employees happen
all of that goes into that hcm suite and
while that might not necessarily be
part of your erp system it certainly
falls within the umbrella the larger
category
of what erp is and so while it might be
a tightly coupled system
it might also be integrated in it really
just depends on which one you've picked
and then also another tightly coupled
system that
may or may not be part of the erp suite
is your accounting system now some
companies obviously choose to put their
erp
and their accounting software together
some of them choose to break it apart
but that accounting piece
that is always going to be core because
the data from the accounting piece is
going to feed back into
everything else that you're doing
likewise you're going to have finance
modules these are the ones that are more
tightly coupled and probably built into
the erp
that are going to track all of those
things like your company investments
companies financial status it's going to
ingest all of that data we talked about
before with your assets and things like
that
and it's going to track the financial
health of your company
at a very high level and that high level
is probably the most important part of
your erp system
because everything that we've talked
about everything on this wheel right now
this is about running the business from
a very operational level
but the next step is not just the
operations piece
it's the governance piece so we're going
to remove this database and we're going
to remove these analytics engines and
we're going to put governance right here
in the middle
because every module that we have every
one of these modules
has to feed that data into the holistic
governance picture because executives at
the boardroom level or one step down
from the boardroom level
these executives are going to make the
decisions that they have to make about
the future of the company
these are the strategic level decisions
based on
inputs from all of the modules within
your erp
system it's how you look at the company
health holistically
and that's very different because it's a
roll up
of all of the data from all of the
modules that are in that that are
feeding
into that database and so as we bring
all of this data in we create this
roll-up reporting we create this summary
reporting we put that into dashboards
right so that companies can go out and
the c-suite can look at
a dashboard every morning that's going
to show them the holistic
health of the company from every factory
they had every location they have every
distribution point
what's going on with shipping what's
going on with retail what's going on
with procurement
all of that data feeds into the erp
and it gives the executives involved the
ability to do those strategic
level decisions it's incredibly
important
all in all hopefully i've given you a
good overview of what an erp system is
and why it's so critical to the
successful operation of any modern
company
your erp system is always going to be
core to your daily operation
and because of that selecting the right
cloud provider for running your erp
system
is also critical your business is 24
7 365 and so must be the cloud
on which you run it so if you'd like to
talk more about how to implement a new
erp system from the ground up
or how to transition your existing erp
system into a modern one
you can learn more at ibm.com cloud
sap or you can reach out to your ibm
sales team or your ibm business partner
and we'd love to engage with you on how
to improve your whole company
by improving your erp system